moreau caractères acquis tiers parce que
de l'autre côté du mur il y avait ils
gardent un accent chantant qui invitait
à l'évasion
pour cette quatrième édition de la nuit
de la lecture la médiatique 17 mar à
elancourt avait notamment misé sur ce
duo de conteurs et leur spectacle
improvisé et rêveur rêveuse j'aime bien
partager les histoires avec les gens je
trouve que vraiment ça permet de partir
dans l'imaginaire et ça nourrit les
adultes et les enfants
j'ai très bien mes compétences
les stars étaient magnifiques objectif
de cette manifestation annuelle mettre
en avant la lecture et les lieux associé
cette année à saint quentin en yvelines
toutes les animations étaient concentrés
à elancourt on a 1000 nous faut plus sur
la médiathèque 17 mar qui est une
médiathèque particulière à ces la
première médiathèque du réseau jusqu'à
21h le public a pu assister à des
spectacles ou encore à des séances de
lecture ce rendez vous littéraire marque
est également à saint quentin en
yvelines le premier temps fort de la 19e
édition de la fête du conte
ça serait bien qu'ils fassent ça de plus
plus en plus dans la médiathèque quoi
les gels et les enfants ils ont adoré
c'est génial qui ait sa juste à côté
voilà après on a toujours envie de plus
parce que ça nous fait voyager et pour
donner encore plus envie de dévorer les
mots il était possible de déguster ses
personnages de conte préféré sous forme
de cupcakes et autres gourmandises
[Musique]